antonio cenzatella making his 23rd start
of the year and of late as we were just
discussing spilling he's been really
good it's going to be ozzy alves back in
the lineup great to see number one in
there
swing and a fly ball deep center at the
track at the wall welcome back ozzy
albies
24th home run for ozzy albees well
that's one guy i don't have to tell to
be aggressive he's gonna do it no matter
what how about that a couple nights off
dead center welcome back askari noah the
23 year old out of puerto plata
dominican republic
straw came out
two good sliders in that sequence yeah
that one especially you talk about bite
to it
and strike three paints the corner
wow
99. back to back strikeouts for inoah
two up two down well charlie blackman
will stand in
and this caused tomahawk to deep right
center this has got a chance it is gone
charlie blackman
who spends a whole lot of time in
atlanta georgia with his second home run
against the braves it is benny knights
retired
they called him a weapon of mass
production
as this one is shot toward the gap and a
diving try by tapia can't get it it's
behind him and up against the wall duval
around second he's on his way to third
and he's gonna make it there standing up
with one out second triple for adam
duvall his fifth hit of the road trip
and the braves come right back now
runner at third with one down for eddie
rosario ball into strike
i fly ball toward left that should be
deep enough connor joe the catch duvall
is going to tag and score and rosario in
the eighth spot in the order a sac fly
to put atlanta in front there's nothing
more beautiful than abc baseball braves
leading two to one and this ball toward
the gap in right center field and
solaire is gonna have to
go and fetch it off the fence and don
nunez has himself a double that was a
high quality at bat for nunez two on and
one out two strikes on rogers
and this is through the right side base
hit dom nunez will come around to tie up
the game connor joe to third brandon
rogers coming through with his 39th rbi
inside out swing two strikes fastball uh
oh connor joe might have got hurt
connor but around second base not a good
sign was grabbing at the back of his
right leg the hamstring area garrett
hampton's going to replace connor joe
fly ball to left field hanson can fly
getting behind it is rosario and
garrett will score easily
3-2 colorado second rbi of the night for
charlie blackman is sixth in this series
no balls two strikes
and a soft line drive to second ozzie in
the shift did you see the spin that's
what i said you see ozzy looking at it
it was starting to cut
and then tail bottom of five rockies up
three to two over the braves
he went around good pitch by noah to get
the lead off man good start to the
inning there's off number one good tight
slider bottom of the strike zone since
attella tried to bunt the runner over
from second to third last time up kids
pitching great
needs a little offensive help tonight
the pitch
hey struck him out back-to-back
strikeouts for wascar that's how the
game started here's hampton his first
hit bat in the night
here comes you know his 81st pitch
and strike three hampson thought it was
down and he noah just struck out the
side and freddie freeman the batter 1-0
pitch
swing and a fly ball that's curling away
from hampson he'll play it on a big hop
and freddy freeman's chugging for two
the throw
not in time he got in
freddy said no you didn't tag me in time
a hustle double for freddie freeman
again the depth of this ballpark gives
the base runners a chance to take
liberties and freddie damn base hit from
riley could get the game tied 2-2
swing and a shot headed for the corner
riley comes through again freeman
gallops home riley headed for second
he's out
and austin says check the play
i don't know what's going to happen on
that play but you saw freddie freeman
speed up at the end knowing that that
ball came back quick so he did get to
home plate though and the run definitely
is going to count regardless of the
outcome until the verdict is in and
they're going to say he's out braves tie
it up here in the sixth inning two hours
story rocky's clean up pitter
and this ball is toward the gap in left
center nobody's going to touch this one
and it's going to take a couple of hops
and go to the wall trevor will stop at
second with a two-out double
and the beat goes on slider up split the
gap
get yourself in score position for cj
crone
pulled toward the whole on through
trevor story around third will come home
and the rockies take a 4-3 lead
guess who again
cj crone rbi number 78. 71 pitches in
seventh inning travis dorneau will lead
off
another ground ball another opportunity
for story
dorno retired two outs adam duvall comes
up
he's gonna have his 12th ground ball out
right here
he's doing his thing he is doing his
thing veteran jolie shotseen making his
35th appearance
jason rosario who hammers one fair and
into the right field corner great start
for atlanta
rosario on his way to second he'll stop
there with a lead off double his bat is
lively and the braves are in business
lead off man on in a one-run game one
out for ozzy albies
runner goals rosario
they got him
rosario tried to steal third and is
tagged out if that's bang bang he has to
be safe misdemeanor oh absolutely safe
this one's got to be overturned the call
on the field takes precedence
either confirmed or
there's not enough evidence so that
changes things dramatically instead of a
runner at second or third with one out
they're empty with two outs for all bees
and the pitch
is golfed in the air to shallow right
back goes story plenty of room for him
and chasing is a big bullet one out away
the dangerous austin riley
long drop center field hampton's got to
beat
one two three of the ninth and the
rockies can shake hands
four three colorado
senzutella with the victory he continues
to throw the baseball exceedingly well
and all around a really good friday
night in lower downtown denver
you